okay sinee so you this this a true story
um did your father like throw you into
sharks at some point in your life see it
sounds crazy and UNT it sounds like
someone should have called child
services but fair enough it's true it
was a controlled environment it was very
safe okay swimming with a shark
experience and my dad I was seriously
afraid of them he thought it'd be funny
to throw some Chum in my one piece and
shove me right in and she's also a
horrible swimmer and I'm a bad swimmer
so it was just a really I I I don't
think I talked to you the rest of the
trip I was very upset oh my God I wanted
to see if the sharks fight no you did
not I got two other daughters I got two
other daughters thank you the fact that
he was like I'm going to put Chum in
there I know well now I know where I
stand on the leader board I
know have you gotten him
back I did something a little naughty um
first season I pretended I was pregnant
can you imagine I I did I mean on camera
so it you know she made a birthday cake
with all these goofy baby no but by the
way Kelly it was my mom's idea so
that like Baby Parts like you know I
actually thought he was going to have a
heart attack and I say like Freddy
Krueger by way it was on his birthday oh
my
God I love your women so much and your
family we got to Dish it back you know I
know you threw her into sharks with Chum
I did like I'm like you she gets like
five more
things that's horrify you guys kep
saying oh they don't bite I go it's a
shark maybe you have one there has
emotional Problem by the way we all got
in the water guess who stayed on the
boat he did not put for sure he didn't
put his toe in the water we all swam
with them the whole time you can have
the water I'm staying on the land the
shark you know what I mean I'm up
[Music]
already
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home